a bald Matt Damon kicks ass in the
future while wearing a metallic suit
drilled into the bones of his body I
don't even have to know the plot of this
movie I'm already interested Elysium is
directed by Neill Blomkamp now he's
coming off with a very successful
district 9 that was a movie that not
only did people enjoy but critics really
hailed as an intelligent piece of
science fiction and that was a really
impressive movie with great special
effects and a really interesting story
that actually had a lot to say about
society went into that movie expecting a
certain thing and it really sidestepped
to you in a good way so a lot of people
were really looking forward to Elysium
myself included in the future earth is
populated with the poorest of society
people who don't have anything everyone
works in factory jobs there are robotic
police officers that treat everyone
horribly people are beaten sometimes for
not doing anything because of some sort
of law that these robots have into their
heads they think people are breaking
laws sometimes they're not people are
sick and dying and they're not getting
the help they need the rich and wealthy
now live in space at this place called
Elysium
it's the circular Space Station like
thing that allows them to preserve their
privileged lifestyle they have Med beds
there where you can be instantly healed
from any ailment that you have no matter
what it is so a lot of people on earth
want to escape to Elysium Matt Damon
included for reasons I'm not gonna get
into because none of the trailers really
gave it away and I like that about the
trailers for this movie so how do I feel
about Elysium for one Matt Damon is
terrific in this movie he did a really
great job with his role I thought he was
really sympathetic I really cared about
his character he was great in the action
scenes you really could tell that he was
doing a lot of stunt work on his own you
really felt sympathy form you really
felt behind him as a person he had a
good past life that really added to the
depth of his character and he was just a
really badass character too he was the
kind of guy you could really get behind
and say yes this is the kind of guy that
I want to see stand up against this
corrupt system that's now been created
because you really started to feel that
in this movie as well that you really
just wanted to see someone stand up
against the corruption that is on earth
now everything is dirty and barren
things that are futuristic don't look
clean and polished it was a very dirty
and realistic look at the future and I
love that about this movie they really
set up a really cool location that
really felt like it had some gritty
realism to it
Elysium to me was a terrific sci-fi
movie I really got behind every scene in
this movie I felt that the characters
were interesting I thought the use of
special effects was terrific
I loved the third act of this movie I
mean I really enjoyed the first two acts
I thought that it was building up cool
characters there were some really fun
scenes but as soon as Damon got that
suit melded to his body I thought the
movie just propelled to this really
awesome fun movie and I really enjoyed
the fact that the director didn't try to
repeat himself again even though there
were certain elements of district 9 that
are definitely here for one it's
definitely a science fiction movie that
has social commentary in it but it's not
quite as brainy or thought-provoking as
district 9 was but it's definitely not
trying to be either and I think if you
discredit the film for that or say that
it's not as good as district 9 this
isn't a sequel to district 9 it's not
the same storyline this is a completely
different movie I can understand someone
comparing the two films but it's not
trying to do a district 9 to trying to
do this is trying to be a fun summer
film with a likeable character with a
good dramatic story and it's also trying
to say some interesting things about
society and I really thought they
succeeded Jodie Foster plays this sort
of corrupt politician of sorts that's up
on Elysium trying to get things her way
and unfortunately to me she was the
weakest link of this movie I really like
her as an actress but her character
eventually was kind of just there to set
certain things in motion that had to
propel the script along propel the story
along and I really didn't buy a lot of
her performance a lot of her lines felt
like they were audio dubbed and she had
this sort of accent that just didn't
feel like it was on the same level of
realism that the rest of the actors were
wrong I didn't really feel that she
brought something to the movie that
really helped it that much unfortunately
definitely not true of sharlto copley he
was great in this movie he's one of the
best villains of the year so far
terrific terrific performance he was
dark and gritty and grimy and nasty and
really really good in this movie he just
had a great physicality to him as an
actor even when he wasn't doing anything
he really emot-- it through the screen
this this evil guy and he could just
like smell it through the screen he did
such a good job
I really enjoyed Elysium the special
effects were fantastic it had some
terrific fight scenes and some really
innovative camerawork had a story I
could really get behind - I really
wanted to root for the underdog in the
movie and it just did it for
I really enjoyed this film I thought it
was a really good and needed last little
injection of summer fun I'm gonna give
Elysium and a - I'm definitely gonna
pick it up on blu-ray when it comes out
and these are the kind of sci-fi movies
I really dig these realistic kind of
dirty grimy visions of the future like
the original Star Wars it wasn't all
clean and pristine and perfect things
were messed up and I really dug that
about Elysium so guys last night my
buddies from one of my favorite movie
review channels on YouTube pretty much
it invaded my house we had a lot of fun
we actually saw at least him together
and they were kind enough to let me
guest star in their review of it which
is on their Channel right now if you
want to go over there and check us out
we're all here sitting on my floor
talking about Elysium so check them out
subscribe to them and guys thanks very
much for watching as always and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]